une visite avec une guide conférencière
dans les règles de l'art
une visite avec pour guide son
smartphone la cathédrale de bourges
révèlent tous ses secrets aux touristes
mais alors visite guidée avec ou sans
technologie quelle est la formule la
plus appréciée on va faire un premier
arrêt ici à la façade sud de la
cathédrale ce groupe d'une dizaine de
personnes a opté pour une visite de la
cathédrale avec les explications
éclairées de cette spécialiste du
patrimoine dès juillet hamid est là pour
répondre aux questions
voyons fait jamais la même visite quand
on a un groupe de personnes moi je vois
les gens là quelque chose qui se passe
il ya un retour qui se fait et je ne
fais jamais la même visiblement je
trouve qu'elle a un avantage avec les
applications sait qu'on peut le faire à
tout moment mais pas obligé d'attendre
un horaire fixe mais quand on a le temps
comme aujourd'hui avec l'autre le temps
qui fait par exemple dehors de se poser
et de visites et bien là
la cathédrale et ben du coup une
conférencière c'est quand même très bien
pour pour prendre son temps et bien
découvrir le monument cette famille
originaire de paris a décidé de faire
halte à bourges sur le chemin des
vacances brice fit s'amender noémie opté
pour la visite avec l'application les
jeunes d'heure
puis 480 la tour de gauche au bar
je sais plus tôt et en soit c'est plus
intéressant quand roues je trouve parce
qu'on prend notre temps et c'est un
petit peu
comme la chasse au trésor ben je trouve
que c est parce que c'est plus détaillée
et c'est sûr que je sais du coup ça
m'intéresse plus que si on était en
groupe pas de perdants dans ce match
donc les visites quitté classiques sont
toujours autant appréciée et
l'application permet d'attirer un
nouveau public plus jeune vous souhaité
s'adresser à un public différent qui
n'est pas forcément amateur de visites
guidées et par ce biais de l'intéressé
au patrimoine donc avec un donc une
cible différente qui serait plus un
public plutôt familial
non c'est en juillet l'application a
déjà été téléchargé une centaine de fois
trois circuits touristiques sont
disponibles à bourges et main sur yèvre
pour une visite 2.0